hi everyone my name is ava soleimani and
i'm very excited to talk to you today
about how we can bridge computation and
experimentation using novel methods for
uncertainty estimation in machine
learning
i like to first begin by considering a
few exemplary areas in biomedicine in
which machine learning is poised to make
transformative impact
in fact as we've already seen machine
learning has shown tremendous promise in
its potential to help us diagnose
disease for example through automated
analysis of medical images
to understand fundamental biology as in
the case of protein structure prediction
and even to design new therapeutics such
as novel antibiotics or improved gene
therapies
however even as these machine learning
and deep learning approaches continue to
develop and mature they're fundamentally
built on a requirement for experimental
data and experimental validation
and this points to something that's
unique to biomedicine
and that's the fact that so much of it
is driven by human beings and by
physical experimentation
that's both because of the fact that the
data necessary to train these algorithms
is largely experimentally generated
and furthermore because meaningful
deployment of machine learning models
requires experimental or clinical
validation of the predictions they make
in silico
these are two fundamental steps of the
pipeline that can be very difficult to
automate
and critically these studies require
tremendous costs and resources in terms
of personnel material requirements and
also monetary investment
and so this raises a broader question
of if and how we can leverage
computational approaches to try to
intelligently inform experimental
modeling to try to bridge this gap and
alleviate that burden
more concretely we can typically think
of experimentation as the means by which
we make measurements of a biological
chemical or physiological system for
example of a molecule's antibiotic
activity against drug resistant bacteria
and these measurements are used to
generate data on which we can then train
a computational model to predict a
target property or a label that's
relevant and of interest and our problem
at hand
but the fact is that these models will
only be good as the data they see
which in the case of biomedicine can be
very difficult and costly to collect
and it also renders these models
susceptible to failure modes on out of
distribution regions outside those
spaces where they've seen data before
and furthermore while traditional models
can
predict a target label of interest they
don't necessarily provide feedback to us
the human users
on what questions or hypotheses or
regions of the experimental and data
landscapes would be even worthwhile to
investigate and pursue
and so there's really this tremendous
need for new and improved computational
approaches that address these problems
in order to inform downstream
experimentation
and this is where i think that methods
for uncertainty quantification in
machine learning have the potential to
really address these questions and meet
this critical need
and this is because these uncertainty
quantification algorithms can report
back to the user on regions or instances
of the data landscape in which they may
need more information
and so algorithms that quantify
prediction uncertainties could then help
focus experiments on hypotheses that
are
more likely to have a high likelihood of
success which can be especially
important in these areas in which data
acquisition can be slow labor intensive
and costly
and thus from this perspective
uncertainty quantification methods are
really well poised to try to bridge this
gap and try to form an iterative
feedback loop that really tightly
integrates both experimentation and
computational workflows
so in this talk i'll share with you two
ways in we can in which we can leverage
this general framework to use predictive
uncertainties to accelerate experimental
modeling and discovery
and in particular i'll use some of our
recent work in molecular modeling and
drug discovery as an exemplary use case
so first i'll show how we can actually
use
model uncertainty in the context of
explorative active learning to try to
accelerate the experimental labeling
process
and second i'll share how we can
actually deploy model uncertainties for
targeted virtual disk virtual screening
in drug discovery campaigns
so specifically we've worked to develop
uncertainty aware neural network models
of small molecules
where we leveraged a framework called
message passing graph neural networks to
first learn representations of molecular
structures
and designed our algorithm to not only
learn to predict a property associated
with a given molecule input
but also to model the underlying
evidence in support of that prediction
what we call the evidential distribution
and this provides a way to directly
estimate the uncertainty that is
associated with that target property
prediction
and so to achieve this we first needed
to develop an approach for actually
learning these evidential uncertainties
and specifically we developed an
algorithm called evidential deep
learning that tackles this problem of
uncertainty estimation by treating
learning as an evidence acquisition
process
and so instead of predicting just the
target of a learning problem for example
a molecular property we train models to
actually learn a full evidential
distribution on top of this prediction
that captures its associated evidence
and we achieve this by training the
network to output the parameters of this
underlying evidential distribution
through a objective function that first
maximizes our model's fit to the data
and also minimizes its evidence in the
instances where the model is making an
error
and so you can see the behavior of this
algorithm on a simple learning problem
shown here on the left where the model
is trained using data in a particular
set from negative four to positive four
and in this range we see that the
model's predictions align well with the
ground truth but that it starts to fail
on out of distribution regions beyond
this training set
incurring significantly greater
uncertainties and telling us that its
predictions here should not be trusted
and so equipped with this evidential
learning algorithm we then started to
build uncertainty aware molecular
property prediction models
and to do this we trained our neural
network model that operates on a
molecular graph representation to
predict a continuous property associated
with a particular molecule input
and we also train these models to
predict the underlying evidential
uncertainty associated with that
prediction
so when we looked at a model trained to
predict how a given molecule drug would
dock and bind a protein target
what we observed was that when the
evidential model was most confident its
errors were lower shown here by the
strong decreasing trend
and this shows us that as the prediction
confidence increases the error decreases
showing that our uncertainties are well
aligned with our predictions
and so this validated our algorithm and
then we next set out to show
that we can actually leverage these
uncertainties to guide the learning
process itself to achieve a more
efficient experimental workflow and so
in this pipeline we start with a library
of molecules and train a model to
estimate property and uncertainty values
and then based on these estimates
intelligently select a batch of new data
points for experimental labeling and
this is important because it's often
very costly to annotate large data sets
and so we want to intelligently inform
new data acquisition to try to
accelerate this process
and this is where we incorporate
those uncertainty values to try to guide
that acquisition meaningfully
and so after this batch acquisition we
can then experimentally validate that
batch and use it to retrain a model and
repeat this process iteratively
and we can use this general setup within
an active learning workflow to try to
improve the sample efficiency
by which we train models and thus
accelerate the experimental workflow
and specifically we tested this approach
on a data set of organic molecules and
their physical properties
and so within this active learning
paradigm you can see how the model's
performance evolves as new data is
acquired
and we see that more data improves
performance even if it's selected
randomly
however by leveraging these evidential
uncertainties to select new data points
we significantly cut down on the amount
of data that's required to achieve a
given level of accuracy
and we found that our method
significantly outperformed a state of
the art baseline including dropout
sampling
and a second baseline ensemble-based
selection performed close to on par with
our method
critically by achieving leveraging these
evidential uncertainties we found that
we can achieve a significant efficiency
gain in terms of
the amount of data that's required to
achieve a given level of performance
with close to a 20
improvement relative to uh the random
baseline
and so what this shows is that instead
of having humans experimentally validate
and collect an entire training set we
can actually reach nearly the same level
of performance from only 20 of the
experiments
so so far in this first part i've shown
how we can leverage uncertainty for
improved sample efficiency
we next asked whether we could actually
leverage uncertainty at deployment to
try to facilitate virtual screening and
accelerate the discovery of high
performing high confidence drug
candidates that had greater likelihoods
of succeeding in the real world
and so here now that we have a model
that's proposing candidate drugs
the next step is to actually
experimentally validate them against
again using human experiments and the
question is how can we prioritize this
process intelligently
so here we leveraged a pipeline in which
we learned a model on a small
label data set
and then applied it to a larger
discovery data set to get both property
and uncertainty predictions and finally
ranked candidates by both their
predicted property values and applied an
uncertainty based filtering to try to
prioritize candidates for experimental
testing
and in particular we
turn to the question of antimicrobial
resistance and the need for
the the urgent need for the discovery of
new antibiotics and asked whether we
could use
this paradigm to try to facilitate and
accelerate the antibiotic discovery
pipeline
in fact here having a human
experimentally validate thousands of
these molecules and predictions is
indeed already what's typically done in
practice but it's not a scalable
solution
so what we did was we took a small
existing and experimentally validated
data set of small molecules
and used that to train a evidential
model that could both predict
antibiotic activity and associated
uncertainty
and we applied this model to a large
drug repurposing data set to nominate
candidates that
would
high confidence and also had high
predicted values
and this turned out to have a massive
impact on how we actually prioritize
candidates for experimental validation
and deployment
and so here you can see
the visualization of predictive
uncertainties across the chemical space
spanned by both our training data and
our discovery data
and here we found that
regions of the of the data set that were
less populated by the training molecules
were associated with higher
uncertainties uh typical of the
discovery set
and so finally what we did was
we consider the top-ranking molecules
based on their predicted antibiotic
activity and calculated the fraction of
those that were true experimental hits
in the real world
and what was really exciting to see was
that prioritizing candidates based on
predicted uncertainties could
significantly improve the real world
experimental success rate and previously
going from a 80
validation rate with random selection to
over a 90 validation rate uh when we
apply this confidence thresholding
and finally we showed that our method
could actually outperform uh two
baseline methods in
this sample prioritization
and so to conclude today i've showed you
how we can
develop a scalable and modular algorithm
for uncertainty quantification in
molecular modeling and how we can
leverage these uncertainties to improve
the experimental efficiency of drug
discovery workflows
and more generally i think the story
points just to one example of how we can
start to achieve an iterative dialogue
between experimentation and computation
in order to truly and fully realize the
potential of machine learning for
biomedicine
and thank you so much for your attention
and i'm happy for the opportunity and
with that i'll conclude